this is bryan dolby at the ftth council
event in munich where I'm talking to
life ends of all tbox life a day of
celebration today yeah sure is we've
been awarded the operators in category
awards for the five atal home console
for 2012 that came a big as big surprise
for ultrabooks we are a very small
operator in the non most corner of
Europe and getting that acknowledgement
from an international forum like the
fibril home console is very surprisingly
and very very satisfying for us small
but obviously perfectly formed so tell
us a bit of background to the operation
that you have out there yeah we actually
started ten years back and currently we
are the largest fiber to home operator
in in no way and always second in the
world in terms of penetration and we are
providing a full suit of services on to
around 250,000 homes in Norway which is
about twelve percent of the norwegian
market and what are your future plans
further developments of FTTH in the
network what is key to to us is to to be
customer driven and provide services as
the service demands and the customer
behavior is changing and we think one of
the key issues going forward is to adapt
to the changes among customers from
being household customers to be
individual customers which we need to
address with all our needs what have
been some of the challenges that you've
had to overcome in reaching this
position I think the main challenge to
make sound economics out of this is that
you get a significant take rate of
services where you deploy fiber because
it's a rather capital intensive so what
we've done is to sell before we build
and that's be been very crucial for us
to reach the success we've had and we I
think we have the world leading take
rate in the areas we build out fibre
broadband it's around between sixty and
seventy percent a great well that sounds
like a model for others to follow but in
the meantime congratulations on the
award today thank you very much
ftth connects the world when are you
getting connected ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Munich for the ninth edition
of the ftth conference creating a
brighter future